Cette voie que vous entendez celle de Thomas
Pesquet l'astronaute français était en direct
ce jeudi 17 juin avec l'université Paris
Saclay la séance de questions réponses a
été suivi en temps réel par quarante élèves du
lycée Saint François d'Assise de Montigny le
bretonneux depuis l'observatoire de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines. C'est émouvant quand
même parce qu'en fait on fait qu'il en direct
et tout ça après il n'y avait pas énormément de
personnes en plus donc c'était vachement émouvant.
C'était intéressant par rapport à la manière dont
il nous conseillait pour persévérer dans ce
qu'on veut faire, par exemple nous a dit de
toujours saisir les occasions. La connexion a
duré au total dix minutes pas une de plus. Le
cône finalement avec lequel on peut communiquer
a une certaine taille. C'est compliqué surtout
quand il ya beaucoup de monde nous nous on fait
ça régulièrement parce que on a notre propre
satellite et notre propre antenne mais c'est à
chaque fois un challenge malgré tout de recevoir,
de faire la communication avec un satellite.
Avant cette retransmission des animations avec
des interviews et un jeu ont été organisées
objectif mieux comprendre la vie de Thomas
Pesquet à bord et pourquoi pas susciter des
vocations c'est un secteur qui fait rêver mais
c'est aussi l'occasion de montrer que voilà il ya
une multiples métiers de compétences et participer
au développement du spatial aux sciences du
climat et de l'atmosphère est quelque chose qui
est complètement dans l'air du temps la journée
s'est terminée par une visite de l'observatoire de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines de quoi avoir
des étoiles plein les yeux en rentrant à la maison